صباح الخير لكما صباح الخير مشاهدينا
خبرنا اليوم من اليونان وهو خبر سياحي
بطبيعه الحال عن ظاهره ذكيه وفريده
للتاقلم مع المناخ وتغيراته المستمره على
الاقل في اوروبا اذا قوم بعض اصحاب
المنتجعات كما في هذه القريه شبه جزيره
الموندا او الموندا بتمديد فتره الموسم
السياحي في الجزر اليونانيه الذي يمتد
اليوم من مايو الى اكتوبر بدلا من يونيو
الى سبتمبر ويعور الكثير منهم على فرص شمس
ساطعه ومياه زرقاء في فصول من غير المعتاد
ان تكون ربيعيه وصيفيه كشهر اكتوبر الماضي
ويعولون كذلك على الانجازات المدرسيه في
الدول الاوروبيه بهذه الطريقه قد يكون
اطاله الموسم لشهرين اضافيين مخرجا من
ازمه مناخيه واقتصاديه خانقه يعاني منها
قطاع السياحه منذ جائحه كورونا والحرب في
اوكرانيا وهناك خبر اخر وهناك طبعا نتكلم
عن عامل اخر للحد من تفاقم ازمه السياحه
في اوروبا تكمن في التعاون المباشر
والاساسي بين الفنادق وشركات الطيران
فمعظم شركات الطيران العالميه اليوم تعتمد
على بيانات الفنادق لتسيير رحلاتها فهناك
تبادل معلومات بين هذه القطاعات المكمله
المكمله لبعضها البعض استعمل شركه طيران
التي تتشارك في عضويه احدى مجموعه مجموعات
السفر كسكايتيم التي تضم الخطوط الجويه
السعوديه
واعلام الهولنديه على تبادل بيانات
مسافريهم لمعرفه وجهاتهم واين يقدون
اجازاتهم الصيفيه هذا العام وبالتالي تقرر
الشركه العضو في هذا التحالف الجوي بزياده
رحلاتها او رحلاتها الى الوجهه الاكثر
قصدا هذا الصيف
طبعا واستمتع دائما
بتقدر بجمال اليونان
اكيد كاليمارا نوع من انواع الجبن هذا
صباح الخير باليو
ناني قصص خلينا نقول طيب
ليث معروف بانه باليونان
طيب خبرنا شوي هيك بالرجاله بعجاله عن
الجزيره اللي انت
بسرعه بس
هيا جزيره طبعا معروفه انها اكبر جزر
اليونان راويه وعادل ولكن الحلو بهون
المنطقه انه كل منطقه بهاي الجزيره كل ضفه
او كل بنك او كل ساحه لهذه الجزيره يختلف
عن الاخر هون احنا بقريه الموندا بنلاقي
فيك مثلا اذا ابعدنا شوي عن الكاميرا
بنشوف انه في مناطق مختلفه يعني ممكن تكون
هون بس للعائلات بدون اطفال في هذه
المنطقه واذا رحنا شوي لهون بعمق الصوره
بتكون هون برضه يعني العائلات واطفال لانه
بتعرفوا في كتير ناس صاروا يسافروا بدون
ما يكونوا مع اطفالهم او ما بفضلوا يكون
في
ازعاج
بلاش مشاهدينا يزعلوا هي في ناس بفضلوا
يكون بدون اطفال في ناس بيكون في ناس
عندهم
رهاب الحيوانات الاليفه برضو موجود هذا في
في مناطق خاصه وطبعا عدم نشاطات الكثيره
واستمتع بالهدوء الهدوء مكلف كما يقولون
اكثر دائما شكرا جزيلا ليث بازاري من
اليونان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات